i'm not funny
in particular but
the story is funny yeah moments in this
campaign
when you mocked me
i definitely make fun of you and myself
um if you think about this you were
completely anonymous had no business
getting into the great the biggest stage
of politics right and myself and the
early team had combined years of
political experience totaling zero like
we had no business running a
presidential campaign
yet
we outlasted
dozens of sitting centers governors
representatives i said we built the yan
gang with podcasts memes and math the
yang gang you're gonna love this because
this is a book that you were hoping i
would write but it did not and so zach
wrote it
[Music]
for the first time ever the forward
podcast two-part conversation
with the
most important author of our time zach
graudman hey man that's an intro so it's
it's fun because people who have gone
into the pattern know
we do a lot of uh books here a lot of
authors on monday and then you and i
come together on thursdays often to talk
about what's going on so this is like a
a combination uh team up
where this is going to be both us
discussing what's going on and most
importantly discussing longshot how
political nobodies took andrew yang
national and the new playbook that let
us build a movement
by the campaign manager andrean for
president quote by yours truly on the
jacket saying my campaign would never
have reached millions without zach's
leadership and strategies anyone who
wants to make change in the world or who
simply loves an incredible story should
read this book
look at that i will say it is weird i've
done a couple podcasts i haven't come
out yet but i've done a couple pods and
doing more this is another one it's
weird talking about your own book man
we've said this before it's like weird
writing one it's now weirder talking
about it welcome to my world
you're like hey you like that's very
uncomfortable
hey thanks for
reading my work of
i don't say work of art but my work of
labor of love
my
my child that i have birth to the world
long shot i think the and game's gonna
like it though the yang gang you're
gonna love this because this is a book
that you were hoping i would write but
it did not and so zach wrote it uh like
if you're hoping for blow by blow in
scenes and something that feels a bit
more like a screenplay or feature film
that's long shot i think there was a
movie called long shot so when they make
a movie out of this object called
something they call it something cooler
something different uh
what you're
right that uh it's personal when you
write a book i do think you have the
healthiest
relationship with a book i've ever seen
from an author uh first time author
because most authors you can sense that
there's like a real
uh thirst to try and get the book out
there and have it validated you have
like a very healthy thing where you're
like yeah i wrote book proud of it like
it shrug people will
i'm excited about the book but it's not
i think yeah i mean i i honestly i will
you're telling this a bit i think
it's because we spent so much time
and i personally spent so much time
trying to sell your book
and i loved your book i was a fan of you
obviously but i really like one of the
reasons it's probably the biggest reason
i joined your presidential campaign was
because i the book was right and i was
into the book
and that was
for lack of a better phrase
a huge [ __ ] to sell
like it was it was good it was good
yeah it was awful to sell um
and we weren't obviously weren't just
selling books but i was like the message
itself was hard
and
you know you really you didn't make the
new york times bestseller list until
you literally gave it as a gift to liz
warren on one of the debate stages with
you know tens of millions of people
watching um
and we we are already a sensation you
were already a national figure then
right so it's um
books are hard uh the best
you know some of the best books that
make the best seller list or you know
make millions of dollars i sold a couple
like thousands of copies we're talking
tens of thousands of copies not hundreds
of thousands so books are hard it's a
different market so i mean for me i'm
excited it's out there i think it'll do
like it'll be fine and there's been a
lot of you have reached out and said
you're really interested a lot of you
bought it which is exciting but also i
think it'll stand the test of time i
think it's a good story and it'll
be there for
later in my career in life and stuff
hopefully you know my kids will read it
someday it'll be fun again a very very
healthy relationship so we were joking
about
my first book that came out when i was
the head of a non-profit and you're like
oh i should have written a book when i
was still ahead of a non-profit because
then it becomes this
uh gift for the supporters of the
non-profit and the org wants to get
behind it yeah so like this machine of
people hyping it up yes and you know it
kind of has this wholesome tinge
so i'll tell you my arc uh and why i can
relate
um so i started adventure for america in
2011
and then in 2012
i was named one of the 100 most creative
people in business by fast company wow
do you apply for that or they just came
out of nowhere and said we like you it
was totally random what happened was i
met
one one of the or the editor of fast
company at the time uh robert saffian
got it and he just was like huh
and then
and then a month later someone's like
hey we think you should be on this list
uh and at the time
uh i was like well dope you know
anything that helps get the message out
about right um the org
and so i then six months later i got a
call from a literary agent saying hey
have you thought about writing a book
and the because you the literary agent
called me because
they had uh paid like a scout who was
like a junior agent who was meant to
kind of look for interesting author
prospects wow so she found me from the
fast company list
and so i got an email from someone
saying hey i represent uh bird lavelle
literary you should write a book we want
to have lunch with bird and so it was
very flattering i mean you google the
agents very legit and
bird's very legit agent uh and so i have
lunch with him he's like hey
and a bird's like a handsome
well-dressed guy
like you'd be like hey did you totally
write a book like they'd be great
it was very flattering um but here's the
the funny part is that i said no
because i was like i'm busy trying to
start this non-profit writing a book
seems like a lot of work
i'm not sure quite how it helps drive
things for my non-profit so as
flattering as this is i just don't think
i have the time or the energy right
that is uh
i mean it's one of the reasons why
what are the what's the joke like those
who can't do teach which i don't really
love um but you know there's some of
it's like
part of
the reason you start teaching is because
you're not able to do right like if you
are teaching or writing or doing that
you you're you're not operating as much
um it's very difficult to write a book
in general it's harder to do it when
you've got other things on your plate
particularly a startup organization so
uh i felt that i had kovid working to my
advantage um so instead of like going
out some nights because there was
nowhere to go and crank on a boat 2020
was a good year to crank on a book it's
true
um
but no one recruited me to write the
book i had to you know
i don't want to say beg but i had to go
out and ask some agents would you be in
[ __ ] in this story um well hey just the
fact you got an agent and you got a
publisher
is a big deal an accomplishment yeah it
felt great and i mean here's what i've
been saying about the book is that um
the book is about our campaign and it's
um i'm not funny
in particular but
the story is funny yeah
it's a funny story but you mocked me
i definitely make fun of you and myself
you know it was like
accurate like is it really sure yeah
yeah but i would say um as much as the
book is about uh the campaign and um and
you in in our journey it's actually it's
actually not about you um
and that's kind of my
why i wanted to write it is that
if you think about this you were
completely anonymous had no business
getting into the great the biggest stage
of politics right and myself and the
early team had combined years of
political experience totaling zero like
we had no business running a
presidential campaign
yet
we outlasted
dozens of sitting senators governors
representatives
we raised hundreds or millions almost 40
million dollars from hundreds of
thousands of donors in small increments
we
populize a lot of policies not just cash
relief a bunch um that are still talked
about or implemented today
you outpulled our sitting vice president
uh in her home state
qualified for seven debate stages all
these things happened right and we did
not particularly know we're doing we had
no experience right
so to me that is not just telling about
you but that's telling about a bigger
picture and there's something bigger
there and that's why i want to write
about like the game
has changed like split between
what the media is doing the traditional
way of doing things and where most
americans are and you and i were very
clear-eyed in that from the beginning
so that's why i wanted to write because
i felt like it needed like the takeaway
from andrew in your campaign is not ubi
um
and
it's not that this random guy ran for
president the takeaway from andrew in
the campaign was that the game has
changed and we just built a brand and a
movement because of that
almost overnight so
that's why i wrote it and i
hopefully got that message across so so
you say that
we had a grand total of zero years of
political experience and that's no
accident in the sense that anyone i
talked to who had political experience
was so
negative on the idea
yeah you know i mean there was an
inverse relationship between political
experience and thinking andrew gang
should run for president yes for sure
yes um i grew up
uh i was always fascinated my mom was a
teacher my dad was an engineer type so i
was always interested in like
for-profits and non-profits how they
worked together
and while i wanted to be a teacher
coming out of college um
i was close to taking a job for a
venture for america like save the world
like mom
i had a ton of student loan debt so i
took the wall street job
um was the only job offer i had so i
started working on wall street in new
york but i started volunteering i
started suit up how close did you come
to joining teach for america out of
college
in close i i mean mainly because i
didn't have that many job offers i was
not good i tried to like i don't know if
you ever you guys listening have ever
done the tried to do the consulting path
did you explore like no i did not but i
know it well so like you know the path
is like investment banking
consulting uh there's
law medicine and uh
what's the fifth one or this there's six
tech and then uh
yeah okay um
so i was not there's these things called
case studies
that consultants make you do which is
like how many ping pong balls fit into
the empire state building or look at
this
you know here's this problem this
company's having how would you solve it
and i was awful at them awful like so
like i never it was one of the few
things i've like really really tried and
just like this my brain doesn't think
like that big like i don't i'm either
too big picture or two in the weeds in
the on the fly like that
um
and so i didn't have the main job offers
to answer your question i could have
worked at a marketing firm kind of and
then the big tours teacher america in
post katrina new orleans with special
needs kids
or uh work on wall street at ubs um
and
i was i remember walking around campus
like really hating the decision because
you can either
like have a good impact and help a lot
of people make no money
or
make some money but not really care
about your impact at all or have any
impact i hated that
but i was close like teach for america
they kind of forgive your federal loans
they do some good stuff so what a guy
because you owed almost 200 thousand
yeah it was like about 200 which is a
lot it's a lot and then with interest it
you know just ended up being too i think
i ended up paying like 240 i'm on that
range um
that's like with like uh my parents
helped out for like a semester or so
and college was [ __ ] expensive man
yeah dude and then i got some
scholarship money um
it was awful um
my brother did a master's because he
kind of had to fight like he was because
he was graduating in 2000 you know like
we're both graduating 2010 2011 like it
wasn't they weren't good times to
uh be trying to get into banking if you
will as opposed to 2008-9
kind of crisis
[Music]
you know what you love to do you know
what i love to do you know what you do
for six seven eight hours a day or night
it's sleep
and because we love to sleep so much we
really should be paying attention to the
mattress that we're sleeping on you can
get a mattress that's personalized for
you your body type your sleep
preferences at helix
sleep.com you can take a two minute quiz
and they will send you a mattress risk
free don't take my word for it helix was
awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 by gq and wired
magazine it's recommended by
chiropractors and doctors as a go-to
solution
for improving your sleep just go to
helix sleep.com yang take their
two-minute sleep quiz and they will
match you to a customized mattress
10-year warranty 100 nights risk-free i
know it'd be weird to return a mattress
at 9.99 but you can do it helix even has
some financing options if you want to do
some kind of layaway action and helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helixsleep.com
yang get the mattress to the sleepier
life helixsleep.com
so you made the big choice to move to
new york city yeah and join ubs join ubs
i was
my that's the thing i was like i did it
for the money like my first salary was
like
around probably like 60 grand a year i
mean there was a bonus but it wasn't
huge
um i remember had like 200 in my bank
account i had a mattress
like a crock pot that was pretty much
what i moved with um it was in like a
little bit close
uh
and
a [ __ ] ton of debt that was pretty much
it so i was like rent and then loans
start at like 800 a month like that's
where they really get like you like you
have six months just you know save up a
bit
um you know and rent was whatever 1700
it was not a good time um but also like
a fun time new york city is a really
good city to be
you know
yeah you know because you could because
you had roommates in that gym roommates
you can live on top each other you can
find social opportunities we actually
met through one of your roommates right
yeah so my roommate joe guy one of them
uh he's got a joe guy uh
i always be like every time i was mad
i'd be like no more mr nice guy uh he's
a really good guy but uh joe guy's
really good guy but uh
he worked at venture for america and was
like so excited about it um so that's
how we met i was working at ubs i
started suit up
and
i was looking for
legitimacy and that's the thing we felt
on the presidential campaign so suit up
you talked about in the book in detail
but sudup is the nonprofit that you
founded while
uh doing your day job so it's kind of a
lot
yeah so like one of the so i saw two
things i started volunteering a lot just
to keep my sanity for like just pushing
paper if you will or making rich people
richer i was in wealth management um
and i started volunteering at this
school down in
coney island near coney island brooklyn
and we asked the kids like what do you
want to be when you grow up like that
you know just like it wasn't like a
specific survey it was just like the
annual survey right and they all said
they were middle schoolers and they all
basically said they want to be
like lebron james or nicki minaj it was
like or beyonce it was like athlete or
pop stars like 80 or so of the kids
and it was like heartbreaking in a sense
because
i didn't know what i want to be when i
grew up but these kids didn't know what
they could be they didn't know their
options um generally speaking or
like
dentist doctor whatever the more
traditional career career paths seem
just as far-fetched as lebron right um
so
but the other thing i saw was at ubs is
that we in court we being corporate
america were pretty bad at volunteering
um we would do like
we do park cleanups and soup kitchens
we'd build terrible houses we went and
scraped barnacles off the side of the
intrepid which is a military boat here
in new york in like 100 degree heat in
august was awful such a terrible day uh
i just remember
like why do these companies suck so much
at this they don't care and it's not
easy for them so i started just running
my own
volunteer days for my team at ubs
and i was like my kids could would love
to work with you guys for a day so we
did
uh something i thought would be fun
would be like just a business
competition for a day so we brought
my team from ubs down to
a school in brooklyn
and the kids were tasked with being the
ceo of nike for a day and had to create
a new nike shoe so they had to divide
into teams of like 10 they got assigned
ubs coaches
and they had to
you know create that create a design a
new shoe for nike say to pick a target
market and design and brand the shoe and
uh
you know pick a celebrity endorsement
and then act out a commercial or make a
marketing pitch and then the winning
team got real money they got like an
amazon well i learned the hard way don't
give them real cash you can't do giving
middle schoolers cash we give an amazon
gift card
um like the real world now you say then
like you work hard in school you get an
a but you work hard in the real world
you get paid um
and
what happened was like everybody i mean
i say this like humbly but everybody
loved it it was like wow my volunteer
day was actually fun and the kids like
you could see them
like their eyes lighting up like oh [ __ ]
this is why i do math so i can add up
how much my shoes gonna cost like it was
just like this connection for
um and i had you know i've done it now
where teachers have cried to me and you
know the kid that's got the hoodie on in
the corner all day
is the one that lights up the room
because of a project like this
um and what happened was i was working
abs
and we did this once or twice at ubs and
then some guy from pimco called me like
the asset management phone he's like hey
my friend did this volunteer thing can
you guys do it for pimco i was like
i mean i guess so that sounds fun uh the
next thing you know i got more and more
companies calling and i started a a
non-profit and uh
now i'm proud to say it's the
million-dollar organization we've got
nine full-time employees and um we
worked with everybody you name a company
at least in new york um like about 150
corporate partners and tens of thousands
of kids and volunteers um so you show up
to work in 2010 and then you start this
when
2014 so i was like but i'd like f the
round i had like
dabbled i really i founded the org like
lls or the 51c3 was 2014. but probably a
year and a half and i started like
really seeing what this could be but i
iterated a lot anyone who wants to check
it out can go to volunteer suit up dot
org uh to see it's a thriving
non-profit that zach started so you
started in 2014
and then joe introduces the two of us in
what 1516 yeah when i was looking to be
more legit uh so i was looking so in the
campaign we're looking for legitimacy
and this is a big thing especially we're
selling to legitimate buyers right let's
call it companies
um
they wanted to know was i real was i
was this a legitimate thing right um so
i was looking just for like cool people
to say hey uh will you put your name on
us i remember meeting with you i was
excited to meet with you because you
also were you'd start a non-profit there
was stuff i wanted to pick your brain on
and you i gave you a pitch like this
great you ask a couple questions like
this is awesome man how can i help and i
was like can i you join our advisory
board the ask is lily just let me put
your name on the website so i can say
yeah these are cool people that think
this is a good idea
and you like did not miss be like
absolutely man and it was like very
andrea like yeah let's do it um which i
love we'll always respect that um
because
it costs you essentially nothing i mean
like if the org
you know was
you know stealing money or something i
guess maybe it would hurt you but that's
probably
it um
but it helped me tremendously right um
cause i was looking the model is
companies pay us to run the volunteer
days so it's a it's essentially a
business so i was when having andrew
yang i was able to get other people and
then
and now i don't have a legitimacy
problem anymore which is great but
that's the hardest part when you're
first starting out you know well you
know other companies just look at the
company roster and they're just like
yeah yeah like oh well goldman did it
but it is a startup thing you have to
find a way to give yourself that
uh legitimacy halo
now if you're a serial founder then you
can skip that part sort of because
everyone's like oh like you know you
yeah right that's once you it's your
first i mean you're 24 right i'm like
trying to earn my stripes
so that was impressive and then
uh you and i connected a couple years
later when i was uh
talking about automation and trying to
run for president i remember
when
and you write about this in detail in
the book where you're like oh no yang i
have to sit through a venture for
american spiel
but then i was like wow this is
different and like i went down a totally
different path so you used to so we
ended up so i ended up uh i was in
corporate strategy when suit up was like
really taking off and i was running and
uh so i had these two jobs and my boss
at the time was like well look why don't
you check out our client philanthropy
team which didn't really exist
uh it was big we were big in europe but
we weren't big in the americas which is
the biggest philanthropy market in the
world we give the united states gives
more than any other country pretty much
combined like we are huge big big
charity world here um
and so built this to help build this
team that uh helped our biggest clients
give money to charity so i used to
invite you to come to a bunch of
philanthropy events the ues events were
such a blast a ton of fun uh
and
it was always a hit so it's funny
because like when andrew eventually told
me he was you know get into politics i i
had seen him somewhat debate and knew
you had like the chops to kind of cut
through really well um because seeing
you on panels and speaking and stuff but
uh
yeah i was at these we used to do these
these jeffersonian roundtable
discussions
which is like a pretentious way i talk
about in the book of like just like 15
people talking about a topic and
you actually hammer it in your new book
forward on like what do you call
constructive institutionalism yeah which
is a lot of people just talking about
the problems and
potential solutions but no one actually
doing anything um it was very like much
like that and this was on the future
work you were not on the invite list or
maybe on the invite you weren't on the
guess like the rsvp list
and you showed up my god
i don't want to hear the yang venture
for america pitch again also like
you were like a level above me in terms
of like uh charisma and uh
like
accomplishment so i was like yang's
gonna suck the energy out of the room
from from like from what i was trying to
get right i was like oh damn it and then
you came in and did
essentially the automation bomb and
you're like this was fresh guys this was
2017
maybe summer i had the dates uh in the
book uh it was early it might even
spring um it's fresh off the 2016
election
and you're like
you know talking about
these are the top five jobs in the
united states most people in half the
country works in them and what they all
have in common we're going to automate
them away if you don't believe me look
at manufacturing we've already automated
on my half of these and where do we do
it pennsylvania michigan wisconsin ohio
what do they all have in common those
are states that went from blue to red
they flipped the trump in 2016 and
that's why you won
and then you said we need to go to
universal basic income as soon as
possible so i'm running for president on
a platform of universal basic income in
2020.
and the room is like silent
like
president of america like president of
the country and that joke never gets old
for me because that's literally
everything everybody's thinking
but it um
hit me like ton of bricks like some of
these folks are like laughing or didn't
get it and the rest was just like after
that they're just picking you apart on
whether or not you could win or politics
but for me i don't know why i think it's
because
i grew up middle class i grew up
like kind of like kicking scratch from
crawl my way just to get a you know
added loans like out of student loan
debt
and it just didn't feel like a very
sustainable path for my friends from
high school like where i thought were
smart and talented but maybe not great
at school um
and
like the folks that were left behind in
the economy or struggling in the economy
more than i was this all checked out it
all resonated really well you know yeah
i mean there were parts of connecticut
that certainly resembled this
post-industrial
former manufacturing towns the other
thing is that you'd seen the limits of
big philanthropy and you were like well
this isn't going to solve the problem oh
yeah i knew no one was going to solve it
like i knew the people with money had no
idea this was happening and would not
know how to do it how to fix it if they
if they did because i'd seen
billionaires
people with quote unquote unlimited
money
still not be able to solve [ __ ]
problems because those are hard um
the other thing is um my dad lost his
job uh or it was image like had some job
transition stuff when i was a kid
i've seen the impact of that on families
it's awful and my dad was able to bounce
back and like it wasn't like a long long
period of time but
um
it's like there was it still is but less
so but there's a real tie between a man
and his identity and his family in terms
of providing yeah and
that was rough my dad was great about it
but i learned it more as i got older
i was able to look back but
just imagining like entire communities
dealing with what my dad dealt with was
like of course like
and who would you blame like whoever's
in charge who was in charge during this
time the clintons right um totally made
sense
um and for some reason like no one
no one got it it was i was just shocked
people weren't jumping out of their
seats to help you you know um and then
you know the longer i did the more made
sense knowing what i knew about
philanthropy well i mean your book goes
into that in painstaking details sort of
fun reliving
the fancy salons of the early days where
people would be very happy to share an
opinion and not as happy to roll their
sleeves or do anything
so i remember that dinner too uh i had
just
finished like a rough draft of like the
first part of the book um so when you
and i were connecting later like i was
like i'm like sending you chapters
that's not done so you kind of see the
book come together in real time
but i remember at the end of that dinner
you said to me like hey man like i want
to help
and then i
was like wow zach would be great and i'm
not sure if you and i
used the words campaign manager even
that i think it was like implied that
it'd be like a leadership position but
it was we had to talk about finance
director too
we weren't sure i think
i'm not sure but i i remember walking
out being like if if i get zach that
would be a freaking
uh
home run uh and i wasn't sure if it was
going to be campaign manager or
financial i knew that you'd obviously
worked with a lot of rich people at ups
i was like
that's a win
um but also you were
a social entrepreneur that i knew like
had
been through a bunch
um and so that like i came away
feeling like wow i really have to try
and get zach out of this campaign
and i don't know how i didn't know how
serious you were at the time because
it's like well it's obviously a big
[ __ ] leap to go from
like a very
um
sought after corporate job to the crazy
presidential campaign uh which is one
reason why i resolved to send you
uh chapters of the book as it as they
were being written yeah i remember it's
so funny because i got to when writing
this book i got to dive into like our
correspondence at the time and i found
some old emails and such and uh
you had said like let's let's get caught
let's catch up let's get launched
something and we ended up getting coffee
a couple blocks away from my office and
you show up you hand me you like slid it
to me almost like pretty almost i don't
think you intended to be dramatic it was
almost kind of dramatic like sliding the
book across the table but you handed me
andy stern's book called raising the
floor
um
and you crushed a brownie there which
was hilarious and i didn't know you're
just like
like talking talking i'm not it was
awesome um but it was tell me about ubi
your plans and then i remember um i
remember you showing me i talked about
this in a book but uh
the washington post uh has like a cool
infographic on how much money people
raised in the prior elections and i said
you know do you think you can win what's
your plan and you're like well
you know it's well we really have to
raise like a couple million dollars um
and i think i can do that with techies
who are interested in universal basic
income and the asians there's no asian
american candidates really in the field
um
and then if i can get and here's what
the republicans did and you were showing
me it was like and republicans use super
pac money so numbers are different but
if you looked at like
you know mike huckabee and chris
christie and folks like we could you
know we like if we could raise what they
raised uh if they didn't raise that much
and like so if you raise what they
raised you'd be theoretically as
legitimate right um
so there was a plan um and then you sent
me a really positive email i can't i
quote in the book but it's like you know
let's go change the world or something
like uh i'm on fire for this something
like that a very classic uh
entrepreneur against the world type
energy but yeah it was uh
it wasn't until i read the whole book
where i was like yeah man wow yeah i
eventually got the book in piecemeal but
yeah
yeah i'm super grateful to your brother
jordan because he it sounds like he put
you up to it in part i i appreciate the
fact that you guys are reading it
together too yeah really wait so i said
to jordan like all right you read it
i'll read it because we both like he had
another year two of getting out of debt
i was finally out of debt that's like my
timing i'm like i'm out like i feel like
i just wasted [ __ ]
years of my life i gave you something
crazy um that matters
and
um i always thought i want to run for
office someday so i was like exploring
politics in some ways
i regret that
i don't regret that decision but like
you know
well
uh conrad taylor on our it was on our
campaign too like like political die
hard and then
he did the uh the mayor's race more in
depth and he's like i don't think i can
do this
but yeah you uh
uh
but we both read it together and it was
like uh
you know let me know what you think you
know we'll give our judgment separately
and i jumped out of my bed during part
of it was like and there's some data in
there that
we don't talk about enough
the biggest one was not the biggest one
but the one that like hit home to me was
that
everybody talks about
you know wealth inequality the numbers
are crazy and going out like the average
income of
certain demographics in the united
states are awful like the average income
of a black male was what eleven thousand
dollars or net worth net worth that's
all like eleven thousand something like
ten percent of that of a
um white family
it was awful and then the other thing
was um
of the rich the people that are
quote-unquote succeeding in this economy
they're just as miserable like their
mental health their happiness their
future prospects you name it everybody's
miserable this isn't even working for
the rich and i was like holy cow um
and you actually had some solutions in
there you know like ubi
um you know obviously he's never like
nothing's a silver bullet but it would
theoretically um
alleviate a lot of this pain right um
so
yeah i was like well i think my brother
said i mean like you're an idiot uh he's
i think it was really he said you're
like you're full of [ __ ] in terms of you
you say you want to change the world so
you want to like leave a legacy and have
an impact in this place you're full of
[ __ ] if you don't take the job uh
because the other day the book was right
like you were right um and i still
believe that and that you know win or
lose we were gonna be right
want to talk to you guys about a new
sponsor we have called air table and if
you've ever tried to do any sort of
leadership activity or startup you have
seen airtable at least be offered to you
as an awesome solution in this ever
changing landscape of work how can you
ensure your people workflows and data
stay connected airtable is how airtable
allows you to create flexible systems
that help your team operate as one i've
used it a few times different orgs and
it's fantastic so break down the
barriers that leave teams feeling
disconnected with airtable your team
works from a single source of truth that
is always up to date and keeps everyone
on the same page so with their adaptable
approach everyone from marketers to
product teams to podcast producers can
build tools that fit uniquely to the way
they work plus airtable keeps individual
projects connected to your higher level
goals so you never lose sight of what
you're working toward it's pretty
awesome so give it a try for free at
airtable.com today that's
airtable.com to get started for free
check it out guys a massively helpful
tool
you know so i i will say
that
um writing the war on normal people
was
almost like a spiritual experience for
me hmm oh so like that uh what's that
song in hamilton i wrote my way out yeah
it really was i wrote my way out so i'm
gonna backtrack a little bit
um so i eventually call that agent back
and be like hey like what does it mean
to write a book um when i was trying to
elevate the profile of venture for
america and i realized a book might be
helpful yeah um and so i wrote that book
and it had you know some modest success
and then
uh i
um just forgot about it i was like well
all right just like
there we go yeah yeah it's like oh
that's that
uh and when i say modest success i mean
like frankly like it felt disappointing
at the time
because i think if you're anyone aside
from you zach like you write a book
and you imagine that people are going to
be like this is like really important
like tell them
that's it like imagine if i wrote a book
my first time i wasn't familiar with the
space i'd be like it's going to be a new
york times best seller everybody reads
he's going to love it tell all their
friends and sell thousands of copies
reality is you're going to sell
50 with your closest friends and family
if you're lucky and then you'll skid
your way to a couple hundred and no one
will give a [ __ ] uh
that's probably the first author's
you know traditional path i imagine yeah
yeah i mean you know so in my case i
sold you know i mean i i i sold you know
whatever like 10 000 copies or something
like that yeah and uh it's great your
first book
yeah that was wonderful
thanks that's what i'm saying the
non-profit probably helped you get all
the fellas
like people had to the book is good
though read it if they wanted to apply
yeah
no they did not have to read it
but you totally would a lot of
read the book of course i mean you're
selling a vision too like that's
um
of course absolutely i mean most people
joined the campaign read the book right
um
uh so
so it became like the you know a
document for people who are you're
manifest interested in
inventor for america yes um so that's in
2014
and then i decided to run for president
in 2017. i call my agent uh uh bird and
i'm like hey man i want to write another
book it's about automation uh ubi fourth
industrial revolution it's gonna be like
the foundation my presidential campaign
so we write a book proposal and it's
like andrew yang entrepreneur is gonna
run for president on the ideas in this
book sold ten thousand last time yeah
yeah and and so uh and and so this was
all i guess somewhat discouraging so the
first thing you do is you go back to
your previous publisher in this case
harper collins and be like hey your
author andreas and we're into the book
what do you think and then harpercon is
passed
and then
harper has passed we're now going to go
to
other publishers and pitch like you know
this book so uh we got very very few
bites yeah um it was
you know like bird who's incredibly
positive
was actually concerned
like
like not sure if this book's going to
find a publisher
um and so then uh hachette ended up
making an offer
um and it was pretty much the only offer
so you know thank you paul whitlach um
thanks paul and then burton was like
take this off
like there was no like oh she's like
right he's like take the offer so i was
like all right i take it and then that
summer i wrote the war on normal people
and
it felt like uh like there were all of
these these ideas that i'd had on some
level but had never really
fleshed out
uh and so i'd go around and find facts
and then the facts were
frankly staggeringly like you know
concerning um but you were also front
row seeing
like the byproduct of this right like
you're seeing the young
superstars come out of college right and
like yeah i had that vantage point i i'd
spent five years in the midwest and the
south so i had that vantage point um so
i was stringing together these thoughts
that became chapters for war on on
normal people and then when the book was
done
i felt
i very vividly i was like if this is the
best thing i ever do
i'm fine with it really like
like if this book is my favorite
major contribution
to
american life of the world like fine
like this is the this is the best i'm
ever going to do yeah um and then that
book when it came out in early 2018 to
your earlier point
did not make it then no like people were
not and at that point you'd read it and
you were also like me being like hey
this book's really good and important
like
more people need to read everybody needs
to read this yeah yeah and what's
interesting and like fast forward to
today so i wrote another book forward um
the war on normal people still is like
the go-to book for me like it's you know
frankly like you know like it sold now
um last i checked the war on normal
people sold something like 175 000
copies hachette
that really nailed that one you know
yeah
it's like a very very good one like now
he seems alive
because again no publisher like in that
book proposal it said hey andrew gang's
running for president no publisher took
that seriously even hachette which ended
up buying the book did not take it
seriously but imagine being the editor
took a flyer on the andrew yang book
15 months later when andrew yang's like
hawking the book on the democratic
debates
people will be like oh so bird my agent
later said to me he was like andrew uh
you like i have never seen anyone follow
through on a proposal
better than you did because you were
like i'm gonna run for president where
do i mean
like and he said like no publisher
believed that yeah none but then we
actually actually did it did do it
um so
uh so the the the
importance that you're putting on the
war on normal people when you were
deciding whether to join the crazy
campaign or not yeah um makes you feel
really gratified because like that that
book
uh getting you on board is like you know
you know like the the biggest deal for
the success of the campaign um you know
i can imagine because i have no idea
what like what we would have done if you
hadn't been yeah hiring in the early
days very difficult um which you saw
talking about in a book where you showed
up and you were like oh [ __ ] we're like
what have i gotten myself into oh yeah
well so i said i didn't i did my due
diligence i talked to a bunch of your
former people because i knew them from
from joe guy my old roommate um
and then his former bosses and one like
mike torillo used to was like
essentially my job at bench for america
at least for a bit um
uh talked i went to college with him so
i talked to him for a bit um
and they all everybody had really good
things to say but um the biggest one was
that uh
joe joe guy said it best he's like i'll
never say anything bad by andre yang
because
uh
being a part of it was was life-changing
like he put me on a different trajectory
of what i could could be in my life um
and i think i've had that
reaction for a lot of people work
closely with you on the campaign and
that
you are um and i learned from you that
you andrew is a magic maker um and i try
to be a magic maker he's like like
you've sheer force of will you're like
we're gonna [ __ ] run for president
and we're gonna make on making the
[ __ ] debate stage and the asians
gonna line up the techies gonna line up
i don't know how but we're gonna do it
and if you disagree with me
respectfully get the [ __ ] out of my way
like that like that's how you operate um
which i love i really love and it's a
really good
it's like
almost
not completely blind optimism but it's
almost right where it's because you you
do look at the negatives you're very
rational logical guy but you like i'm
choosing to ignore those because we have
to be laser focused on the right mission
so anyway so joy and i'm like andrew's
got me this all hyped up i'm all jacked
up
it's my first day we're like hey we're
staying in my mom's apartment in hell's
kitchen for a little bit until we you
know figure it out
yeah
and uh there was a guy living there but
i showed up and i was like you know it's
like the first day of the rest of my
life type energy and i get there and
it's like
like muhan's not even awake yet like i
live in the apartment it smells like
dude there's just boxes of books like
[ __ ] there's a picture of this like in
the in the book uh actually yeah it's
like there's boxes of books everywhere
um
there's nowhere to sit really uh it's
not a wi-fi it's not fast enough for
three or four people uh
like
it was and like no one's worked on a
campaign before like frawley who was uh
who ended up running our merch um was
like uh
he worked in digital advertising he's
like 23 i think
muhan was like an engineer from a
i think venture for america startup that
didn't go well
um
and me
and eventually carly and matt
and matt was like a lsat teacher at the
time like brilliant policy wonk but
no politics carly never worked on a
campaign
uh yeah that was pretty there were a few
others but that was uh
so yeah i remember you showing up and
then the apartment you know was not
suitable for anything and then one of my
first things was like hey man go find us
an office yes
and you did a great job you found us a
dope
fun office that we ended up
taking over that building in a way yeah
so the the office is on 39th street
uh off of um
between seventh and eighth avenues
um so it's it's adjacent to times square
it was right next to both a
nice
fast casual sushi place
uh next to a comic book shop i used to
frequent in my 20s though nice
on 40th and 7th and right next to a
sports bar called carrigers that uh
there was like a healthy
smell of fried food coming out
so you found this office and the office
was hardwood floors high ceilings
natural light yep uh it was
uh maybe
like
2800 square feet or something like along
those lines
so it but it had a really good vibe to
it yeah um
i don't know how into physical spaces
you are
um i'm pretty into them in the sense
that
if you have a place with natural light
and hardwood floors and high ceilings
and like has a good energy and people
want to be there um i'm so i
saw a couple of these spaces and i think
i seized on that office and was like we
got to get this office was that was that
right that sounds about right um
did a lot yeah that was my first real
big task was
finding an office um
and then you were you were crazy risk
seeking which i i learned to love but at
first like my brain could not handle i
remember like the first
i remember looking at our financials
like all right we've got like
and we were always kind of tight like we
were at like three months of burn
uh
yeah which for those who've never worked
at startup means if if you don't raise
any more money over the next three
months we will run out of cash based on
like our current run rate how much we're
spending per month and then it was like
three months of burn and then you walked
in one day you're like
guys we just hired matt shinners he's
gonna be our head of policy
all right move on i think it's one month
to burn now
like uh
but you were like go for it i remember
we didn't have enough money to hire
carly
well no we were trying to hire a video
editor could not find one uh we
eventually hired this guy luke for a bit
and then eventually leveled up to hire a
bunch but couldn't find one but then
we met carly who we like i obviously i
didn't maybe love at the time i but i'm
engaged to her now so it's different but
i'm not there but um
but we all loved her and we're like this
is good energy we couldn't like before
honestly was clearly brilliant yeah
she's like definitely special and was
helpful um
or like
she had no video editing skills really
uh
like and you're like just do it man this
will work out
okay man
uh
it did work out
ballsy move but uh because we couldn't
afford we could barely afford the video
editor uh which we still didn't hire at
the time uh but yeah obviously she was a
great hire for a number of reasons yeah
no i i i do remember you being like hey
we have this much uh runway and then i i
kept uh throwing logs on the fire and
then the runway kept shrinking i was
like yeah i don't worry about it don't
worry about it
we'll get the money
um that that i was you know confident
one of the things for ollie said to me
early on and i was because like it was
one day you in particular like super
risk seeking i was like i'm like i don't
have to do man like do i need it am i
just like am i just alone for the ride
here because i don't think this makes
any sense and he goes all i know about
andrew
is that
when his back is against the wall
he was not going to lose like if you
told him like hey payday is due tomorrow
we need to we need to [ __ ] raise all
of it right now
like he'll raise money
uh that's true you're good at that um i
don't know if it's like a it's not a
procrastination thing you're not like a
uh
i'm i'm like a fairly buttoned-up
hard-nosed
operator yeah um but the the deltas at
that point in the campaign just did not
concern me yeah i was like plus minus 50
100 grand whatever yeah
all right you know i was like look we're
trying to
raise you know millions
uh and then uh we were scheduled
and that meant how they like pretty much
hit us once we booked joe rogan
so that was booked like six weeks in
advance like it's uh
uh which i'm really getting ahead of
myself but we were weeds burned out like
we were pretty much bankrupt
that day
like that's how i looked at it uh but
i was like all right we're spending joe
better hit like
well so i mean we can build up to that
but so the dates we're talking about
what was your first day of work on the
campaign was the april i think it was
like march 1st
early march 2018. all right so let me
tell you let me tell everyone what
happened in terms of before zach joined
i was very eager for zach to join i was
like man if zack doesn't join i don't
know what we're going to do for
uh for leadership and like operational
capacity oh yeah you also needed a peer
you had a bunch like the i mean probably
they're great guys they're a lot younger
than you you know um i mean i was i mean
i was about what i got you know like 11
years on me something like that but like
at least i had worked i had a decade
almost a decade experience like
corporate
is an adult too but chinese wasn't as uh
he was a couple weeks later too yeah he
was a couple weeks later
so and he had a different type of role
yeah so
uh so in 2017 um i spent the fall
um in my mom's apartment with muhan uh
just building the
website
policies putting the finishing touches
on the book
um
and so the campaign was announced to the
world of the new york times in february
of 2018 yes where it's like you know his
message the robots are coming yes uh his
campaign message and you had hat hair in
the photo i didn't know that time but
you're here if you look at that photo
your hair is like
probably yes
almost certainly it's not a bad photo
though uh um and and then my book came
out in april of 2018.
so
you joined between those two dates and
between those two dates we were
still very much finding our footing
and
the the year you described in the in the
book
you know that process where we were uh
just getting our our legs under us
um a bit later in that year and i'm
surprised that you didn't go into detail
in the book about this but there was the
humanity first uh tour
first tour which was in 2018 and you
were literally the bus driver so one of
the jokes on the campaign early on was
that we were the shittiest drivers
anyone had ever seen
because carly for all of our all of her
gifts went away to school and was like
not an experienced driver yeah yeah
carly can't drive she's uh to her credit
she admits she's a bad driver
that was a virtue
our videographer at the time luke hansen
uh luke we love you poor driver
yeah and uh but you know i and for
whatever reason
um it came to you you were like the
um
like the camp counselor
bus driver yep um and so we decided to
go on this tour because liam declivolo
this freaking at the time 19 year old
shows up at our doorstep and is like hey
you know we have this like you know
political
vision and think that you know
yang is the right combination of this
and that but then for whatever reason
liam's like hey you guys need to go on
tour and then i was like that's stupid
because no one would show up to said
tour
and then he said that's why you have to
go on tour and then for whatever reason
that logic worked on me
and then i turned to you and was like
hey man i think we go on tour and you do
your credit this is like maybe the
biggest lift
in the campaign before or after
where you were like all right we're
going to do this but we're going to do
this tour and that tour holy [ __ ]
like where like it was so janky
would show up for the bus and you and
carly like i i
um was blown away that you were sitting
there
together like erecting this like shoddy
backdrop and stage and not not shoddy
because you know you weren't awesome
just the fact that you would get into
the shots and take the things out and so
we went to pittsburgh
we went to detroit we went to
cleveland i think
chicago cleveland pittsburgh
i think i think we added a couple bigger
cities like that we did iowa new
hampshire uh they were in there it's
probably close to all of them so i
didn't so a couple of these things
mismade the cutting room floor because
there's only so much you can write about
how shitty we were so i think that's
where our editor's like probably not and
also trying to keep it moving and keep
it down but um so we did a couple things
so this is fun if anyone knows liam who
uh runs humanity forward um
the five on c4
he shows up
to your i didn't get i'd like i just
joined so i didn't i was not aware of
like the team calendar or yang's
meetings that sort of thing so he shows
up a couple weeks after i'd started to
your mom's apartment
he's in high waters he looks like he's
10.
uh
and he's a hyper nerd like speaking a
mile a minute just all about political
jargon and that sort of thing and he
sits me i'm like who is this kid what
yang what meeting have you just taken
like what is going on
and he sits me down and gives me this
like framework for how someone should
run for president and it's
we still use it on the it's brilliant um
and he's a political junkie and he he
joined the bernie campaign before he
took off he joined the beto campaign
that's why he couldn't work for us
full-time at the time he joined beto
before beto o'rourke was a thing in
texas he's very very good at finding
these candidates um or um
and and yang was like his third looks
like hit if you will um
and so but yeah he's a he's young this
type of people that come in the office
all the time but then we did this
humanity first tour
i remember asking like this is like the
dumb questions we have to ask ourselves
like
besides raising money
like what are you supposed to do when
you're running for president because you
can't just go i mean you could like
spend like that sounds like a dumb
stupid question but actually think about
it like you spend all your time like
trying to talk to iowa voters are you
trying to get press all day long are you
trying to throw a rally like what are
you supposed to do and the answer is
like no one really knows it's pretty
much anything you want but you want some
form of
to drive money polling and crowd sizes
right um
or essentially uh pulling in press um i
talk about those kind of three cars all
connected
um so if your money so imagine three
cars you have money you press and you
have crowds and they're all connected by
a chain
and so if you have one that's really
fast but the other two suck it'll slow
you down um and sometimes they can pull
the others forward but they hold you
back um you want them all cranking and
we had none
we're over three
but yeah liam's like you should go on
tour just to see if you know get some
content of you speaking and see what
happens if uh crowd wise see if you can
get used to building for events and such
so we did and i drove a 15-person
passenger van it was wild uh those are
awful to drive uh
i i really felt for you just like
parking that thing
uh you know it got towed in chicago oh
my gosh you got towed in chicago oh and
my wife evelyn showed up to that event
in chicago with the kids
i forgot about that
i've showed up and then we had so we got
these like uh i basically got a big ass
uh
they're called a step and repeat if you
will they use these big galas that had
like humanity first tour on it like
universal basic income yang 2020 we
tried a couple messages
uh
and then we had to get it to all the
events so we actually ended up buying
two of them and like flew one that took
one to iowa and other places uh
and there was no trunk space in this van
so like but the best the open space in
the middle so we had all the [ __ ] in the
middle of it and then carly and liam
were typically in the back so we draw
like four hour 10 hour drives like two
of us in the front and two of us
literally 15 you know let's call it six
rows away in the back it was very
strange
uh we had these like shitty risers like
milk cartons for andrew to stand i
remember vividly getting on top of the
milk carton yeah and like a shitty uh av
system because we did these events at
like a detroit or whoever would do it
for free like the truth
thank you thank you my friend zach
bashak yeah they're awesome really
really good entrepreneurs that like
liked you they'd heard you on sam harris
or other places um
but talk about like we tried to get
press to come
no no press was coming almost we almost
had someone come but yeah it was like we
just did events that no one was able to
[ __ ] about calling local reporters being
like hey andrew yang is coming to town
yes
we would uh
we took you would take a photo because
we would get chicago we got a couple
hundred people and that was cool um a
lot of sam harris fans of chicago
apparently um
but
we
you know like iowa or detroit you know
you're not getting more than like 20 to
40. but you take the photo
like angled over someone's shoulder to
make the crowd look bigger you know and
so that's how you knew if you guys
wanted like a good tip if you see some a
politician post a photo
and it looks like they've zoomed in
tight to the crowd
it means that there's
yeah you know uh
it's a good
anyway so that was wild yeah that that
tour wow um so so that was one of the
defining experiences of 2018. when
you're trying to perfect your stump
speech too yeah yeah and yeah get better
that too
cause it's hard it's different than
the other speeches you're normally
giving you know
[Music]
yeah so uh around this time and you you
start getting into this in the book uh
is where we start out with a particular
thesis
um which is that we should go to
andrew's fancy friends uh who can write
checks
and
have events and then ask them for money
the maximum you could give the time was
maybe 2 800 something like that so if
you do some math you'd be like hey you
know you get 20 people to give you 2800
that's uh 56 thousand dollars like
you're going to get a monthly burn yeah
so
let's go do that yep um and then you
painstakingly detail in the book why
that did not happen
and one of the things that made me laugh
out loud was like so here's here's the
order of operations um i call a friend
of mine i'm like hey man i'm running for
president they're like yeah yeah yeah i
know be like hey well you have a vet for
me and then it's hard to say no to
someone when they're on the phone with
you when you're their friend so they're
like sure sure um so that i then email
and be like thanks man uh is he seeing
my campaign
who can like uh help plan the event
and then you talk about how they try and
like duck ducks
like they don't get back to you and then
eventually you move them to get a date
on the calendar and then you you you say
the book and then my suffering became
theirs
because then they had the job of trying
to get people to come to an event
for uh presidential campaign uh and they
they start out with these visions of
being like oh everyone's gonna donate
500 bucks to be there and then when they
find that doesn't work then they start
downgrading it to free free
they'll donate after they get here they
don't like yeah andrew will be so
compelling that like that they they they
will yeah nope never happened it was uh
i have the whole there's a whole chapter
in there why why fundraising for
campaign sucks it's awful um
it's one of the biggest gatekeepers to
our shitty political system is that you
have to raise money
you have to play the quantity game
with rich people because you can't if
you're young if you're new to this you
can't crowdfund your way to relevance
out the gate because everyone thinks you
can and you can you cannot because you
need think about you need tens and tens
tens of thousands of people again
for you the the logic that everyone uses
that is a thousand percent wrong do it
hey i've got 10 000 twitter followers so
if only 10 percent of them
give me
uh 25 bucks each that means that i'll be
able to raise 25 000
um by uh just just my twitter followers
if i send a tweet yep in real life how
much will that tweet raise for that
person two hundred dollars yeah probably
like you know
one person will give a hundred bucks
yeah it'll be ten people max will donate
uh
unless they're used to donating to you
uh but even that'd be low yeah so
um so getting
people to donate to our campaign in 2018
was really hand-to-hand combat we had
like a bell we'd bring every time
someone donated that
um i would personally send an email or
note to someone everyone who donated for
a while and then they'd be like is this
really is this real real and i'd be like
thank you for your six dollar donation
yeah thank you thank you you know
that's one of the things you have to do
to try and cultivate early
supporters so uh but you write in the in
the book about how
uh
the average yield from these events was
i mean
you had a dominant item out with twenty
three hundred dollars like something it
was less than the max i think it was
like 4600 it was 46. it was less than
that if the couple done yeah that was
less than a couple max that's it yeah
yeah yeah um i should get used to
nailing my numbers from the book though
because you were good at that when you
talked to me so one of the funny things
too is i would remember
an event being a dud because we had lots
of dead events yeah um but i couldn't
blame you
i couldn't blame my friend the only
person i could blame is me
for not being cool enough
that people want to donate just to show
up and hear me talk or even donate after
hearing me talk because i'm so
compelling
so yeah so from my perspective it was
like well no one to blame it myself
oh it was awful i have a whole chapter
like a page in there and like how the
[ __ ] we would say to ourselves like
each other to like build each other that
was funny too
man they'll donate next time or uh
oh this person uh this famous person had
heard of you they're excited look at
they're following you on twitter like
you're trying to distract you like that
[ __ ] kool-aid we were drinking yeah
that we were like distracting each other
because i will say to you if i was
self-conscious at all it was not for my
own sake but it was for for you because
i'm like oh [ __ ] zach might get
demoralized if like you know these
things yeah keep just being duds um
because again like i would look in the
mirror and be like well it's clearly on
me for just not being good enough or
cool enough um i don't did you feel
self-conscious at the time that you were
like hey i'm not able to probably not
you probably just played me too
i mean it was tough to blame you because
of how
awful it was you know it was just
honestly
um
who did i play i i didn't you didn't
know like for me i'm a big like
try everything once or as many times as
you can see you didn't play anyone
that's good not really yeah i mean like
there were times it was like it was more
like you know like a big thing to me was
uh where i would get mad at is some of
the fundraisers or the
people being full of [ __ ] um this is so
much
full of shitness yes like there's still
a couple people like i'm gonna raise you
tens of thousands of dollars and like
nothing
the worst part is okay here's the deal
i have tried to raise money for people
and failed that's just hard though yeah
and that is acceptable but if that
happens
i damn well better max out yeah
so
like hey my wife and i at least going to
pay
more than we thought that's the
egregious thing yes is that if someone
really exerts themselves or not i mean
they couldn't exert themselves that much
because like
if they're not able to do it then they
just cut the check themselves which is
by the way not you know what they said
they were going to try and do or whatnot
right
and there are people who a thousand
percent could afford that easily yes and
they didn't that's what was frustrating
so that was the frustrating thing for
both of us where we would go to a home
and the home was very fancy it was
easily worth millions and millions of
dollars and then that person would not
donate like a thousand dollars or two
thousand dollars um despite opening
their home up to friends and then being
like hey we should support this person
sometimes even saying like i'm
supporting them and then you really
didn't and they didn't and then you're a
little bit like hey like you didn't tell
all your friends that you donated um so
so like watching things like that unfold
it was a little bit like
you know like
like
no people are full of [ __ ]
where's the character yes it was a lack
of integrity and so now like i make a
note like a friend of mine it's gotta be
a good friend like someone like in my
circle but like if someone asks like hey
i'm fundraising like i will donate i
can't not i'm not rich so like i'll give
what i can because when we did it they
were random friends of mine like like
fringe friends or random colleagues a
friend of a friend that would be like
i'm in man just donated right and those
people like i always made me feel a joy
like thank you and i had some best
friends that didn't do [ __ ]
and
um
it's the i called foss full of [ __ ] um
and that was we you know we felt that
all the time um
politics
brings out a lot of people and you know
people so
uh it was a step worse for me i think as
the candidate so for you they were
like i tried my friends but it's very
different like trying to yeah
i mean you
you know you felt strongly about it and
you were clearly taking a risk and you
know you're dedicating your career so if
someone loves you and supports you
they'll be like all right
um but for the candidate it's like you
know direct yeah so like
someone says my friend andrew's running
for office and like now's the time and
i'm not gonna donate they never [ __ ]
donate you know that's it yeah and so
did i lose friends totally yeah like am
i still pissed off at like some people
that uh
were close to me who just like you could
tell were like more concerned about how
it would reflect on them yeah
totally yeah um so so that stuff
uh you know what that means man they
were never actually a friend
that's what i learned when i left ubs
there were people that like essentially
stopped answering my calls and texts or
stopped coming to things i was throwing
and it was because they were my friend
because of like a friend of convenience
now it's like that's a thing in life
where it's like you have the same you
have the same peers you work at similar
types of jobs and neighborhoods and
social circles and restaurants and all
that you're saying i thought you were
going to use a different word there i
thought you were going to say like
friend of uh like status or friend of
utility because if you were let's say a
different type of friend
wealth management at ubs then people
would be like oh like this person could
be really useful oh if i had my don't
suit up yeah because i was tied to
the job or the status or yeah yeah yes
so when someone takes on a role where
they can no longer do things for people
and then people then lose interest in
that person so that that's like a
utility
uh relationship um
[Music]
yeah it's hard because it's i i grew up
like my parents
my parents are weird and i love them to
death they're fun they're like great but
they had weird weird nerdy friends like
all a lot and i was always when i was a
kid like or what says i got like a
middle school high school to a cool for
school phase i never really understood
but as i got older i understood my
parents have friends that would take a
bullet for them and they still to this
day right if i though i've thrown
surprise parties for my parents and
these friends the type that will fly
from buffalo or from connecticut if
they're in florida wherever it is to
come and they wouldn't miss that for the
world right it's like that
they may have like they may be weird
they may you know their kids are weird
like whatever but um
a real friend and my parents never
valued that and i didn't it took me a
while to learn that actually took me
leaving ubs to realize what the hell
friend means like a friend loves at all
times um
and that shit's biblical so
it was
very yeah like i wrote about this in a
book
no one gives [ __ ] most people do not
give a [ __ ] they say they do they act
like they do
uh on a high level
but
a lot of people as soon as your utility
runs out or the social status runs out
they don't give a [ __ ] and those the
worst part i'm go ahead those are the
same people they're gonna talk about how
good of a friend they are to you and how
well they know you when you are having
success later you're like oh yeah andrew
like someone saw my injury oh you know
i'm i'm
through a fundraiser for him all right
yeah i'm close friends i got a cell
phone right here
[ __ ] you pardon my french but those are
the worst that's the worst it's just
fake
driving nuts sorry yeah though i will
say virtually everyone who threw a
fundraiser for me like you know like
yes the ones who i mean down the stretch
is a shock i'm like certain like we'd go
to fundraisers to raise 100 grand like
um yes mind-blowing down the stretch
yeah yeah so uh so during 2018 what what
was like the darkest moment for you if
you had one do you remember uh because
you write there's like the chapter in
the book uh
2018 darkest moment because so and we're
going to talk about the in the next
uh
chapter of this conversation
um like the turning point of the
campaign when it went positive and then
like what the lessons
uh
you had um so the book goes through
um i'd say several phases and phase one
uh
is like the dark days essentially
the darkest
so there was still like that hope in
optimism in the early days right um
and then
sam harris was a healthy lift and that
was june i think may yeah
and so there was his hope
that
if
we got the message out there to the
right audiences or any big audience
in the right format
it would work because we raised a good
amount of money and had some decent
crowds i mean 100 people in chicago or
almost 300 people in chicago if i recall
that's bigger than everybody but the top
six candidates at the time we're getting
in terms of crowd sizes um
pretty much yeah um so like we had that
we know legitimacy but i would say the
darkest days were sometime between
sam harris and before we found out were
going on joe rogan um
uh because it was like i don't see uh
late 2018 was a difficult time yes so i
i so this summer
uh i'm on sam harris and then right out
of that i get invited to speak at the
iowa wingding that's right which felt
like a big deal yes
and the fact that i went to the iowa
wingding is probably what eventually
landed us in the
um iowa poll that ended up determining
uh debate qualifications that was new
years or so when we found out yeah but
for whatever reason you uh that we had a
running joke that you didn't like iowa
because like you you were tied up that
weekend my brother got married that
weekend yeah that's a big deal i was so
pumped to go and it was my brother's
wedding and i was like obviously jordan
would be fine if i missed rehearsal
dinner and you're like dude stop
just [ __ ] stop i was the best man
[Laughter]
you're missing iowa
so
i go to iowa
and then
there's this period during the summer
where it feels like we're
um making headway but then like the end
of 2018 i thought was a tough time
um
and the midterms really
ended up blotting out a lot of political
energy like no one because like the only
people in the field at that time i think
were like john delaney and me um and so
like no one was thinking about it but
one of the tougher times and we managed
to frame it positively is we had a new
year's fundraiser that year
uh that lost money that at least one
person asked for a refund
um yeah because they were you know so
disappointed in now the refund she was a
little i don't i don't think she was
justifying the refund the party wasn't
that bad like we did give the we did
have open bar and food and decent crowd
but yeah it did lose money yeah it's not
great yeah so you know it failed on its
own terms because it was theoretically a
fundraiser
it was theoretically fundraiser it was
definitely a camera angle type thing
so we you know took some good pictures
but i remember that this person was
disappointed enough and i i think it was
like uh
what what pained me about um her
was that she was clearly a supporter
um and then she showed up and because it
didn't feel
like real enough she actually felt like
it reflected negatively on her that she
was i can't believe i would support this
yeah because like you know it didn't
feel like yeah you know like it was uh
significant enough and so then obviously
we gave her a refund and we're like yeah
sure sorry yeah um but i i do remember
thinking it's like well this is not a
good sign because i i've thrown new
year's eve parties that made money uh
you know as just like uh just as a party
that was the biggest thing a lot of
people didn't want to spend new year's
related to politics in the slightest i
was in hindsight learned that um
anyway uh
but i will i will say this like you
i said as a friend like and i can say
this in hindsight now like knowing you
better
you were taking a lot of the stress and
weight of the campaign personally during
those times like you were not as
probably happy as i've i saw you like
like
from june 2000 or let's call it post joe
rogan is a bit of a rollercoaster like
it's not fair to value anyone's
personality during that like year
stretch
but
knowing you and like your normal
baseline of happiness like you were like
stressed then um taking a lot of this
[ __ ] personally it wasn't every day but
it was it was it was hard on you it was
hard in all of us um the dog days of the
campaign was like winter 2018. winter
2018 was the tough yeah i'd say that no
one cared
midterms that just happened and we're
always like after midterms everyone will
care and almost [ __ ] caring uh yeah
the new candidates were declaring all
the time yeah and uh we were not part of
the conversation
uh you know i'd show up to something and
like people would totally
uh if not ignore me like definitely
there was like a lot of tacit snubbing
going on yup
oh man it was uh
yeah i wrote i have a sample email
verbatim email that i wrote to a
reporter who like
left you like the only i was like
basically hillary on castro i think
announced
and it was like the only other candidate
who's announced his campaign is john
delaney and i was like
and us
talk
were the free hugs guy in their eyes you
know we were there's as i talked about
this like we had to
this is like the point of the book so
we had to compete not just with um
so there's well it's like 1500 democrats
i think that run for office every year
it's 3 000 people across the party run
for president sorry run for president
every cycle
and there's they're only like 29 let's
call it major candidates so what's the
difference between those 29 and the
other thousands
uh is legitimacy and so the free hugs
guy runs there was a woman named lisa
simpson we met who legally changed her
name to be like the simpsons character
like she's running for office like yang
was that to some uh in the early days
and to be fair
there wasn't much difference on paper
because i mean you were impressive guy
but some of these people are you know
regular business folks um
and we had raised some money but we were
trying to get out of that you know that
was hard um
but
and that was the thing so it wasn't we
learned this very quickly um
and painfully was that
we are in
the attention economy
which means attention is the most
valuable resource in order to get all
the other resources you like like time
and money attention is it and what does
that mean it didn't mean we were just
we weren't just competing with the other
candidates not only the free hugs guy
weren't competing against liz warren and
joe biden and bernie sanders and the
usual suspect alone we're also competing
against taylor swift and kim kardashian
and the hbo hit series whatever it is
that friday night and
netflix and whatever spotify whatever is
your friends are texting you everything
that you're getting information loaded
onto you we had to compete with that too
um
and that actually changed the equation
because we didn't have to be
uh
like if we didn't do everything kirsten
gillibrand was doing
it actually didn't matter because no one
was paying attention to her either we
had to we could just we just had to
stand out and get people to realize we
existed and so that kind of flipped the
the mentality it was like we needed to
uh we i ended up calling it create an
identity brand where people can identify
with andrew to make you relevant which
ended up being the birth of the yang
gang which you can take direct credit
for because
um though it was uh an organic internet
someone on the internet
creation really created it but yeah um
but then uh you
built on it despite some resistance the
team hated it internally so
um so the the next segment of this
conversation is going to be essentially
like when the dynamic shifts and we grow
and all of that but give us a glimpse
of what ends up fueling the campaign's
ascent as chronicled in long shot
so how do you compete in the attention
economy two ways volume and relevance
volume is like bud light marketing which
is talking about the book is that when
people just beat you into submission
with their ads or their content right
it's why
target emails you 20 times a day or
bud light has a thousand commercials
it's not because they have anything new
to offer they just want you know they're
there we did not have enough money to do
volume um
so we had to go with a relevance route
we had to make you relevant and relevant
to who um
and we needed to make you relevant to
people that would easily connect so we
created what i call identity branding
where folks identify with you and um
the the ways i talk about the book where
you create a like us persona you find
your tribe and you let them in and so
the like gus persona was branding you in
a way that i felt like like you say like
us in front of us like like us we are
forward-looking and logical i mean like
math or an entrepreneur or whatever it
is right um i mean you could say about
any there's a lot of good brand like
target disney they do this well right
but letting people know this is where we
are like us you can be like us and then
we had to go find them
and
um
finding them
we really wanted something that was
visceral where people could identify
with um so if you think about
2016 as it was the the recent example we
were looking at it was like if you were
voting for john kasich or ted cruz what
would you say like i'm on team kasich or
i'm
voting for ted there was nothing there
but trump
what would you say like people would say
i'm magga
or sometimes i'm on the trump train but
i'm maggot make america great again it
was this visceral like right here people
felt connected to donald
so we wanted that and
someone posts so andrew's army felt lame
uh
team andrew didn't work and then we saw
yang like hashtag yang gang on uh like
in one of our early posts and i was like
that's it that's it because it's
visceral and you could say i'm yang gang
or like i'm kind of yanking am i in the
you can say using a sentence better
um
and
i remember saying the team was like
we're calling it yang gang and i hated
it like carly was like you know it
sounds like gang bang like no one's
gonna like it it's weird
and then uh i remember saying all right
fine
you kept to come up with a better idea
in like i think it was like 10 days or a
week or if not we're going with yan gang
um
and they didn't because it was good it
was good for us you know i wouldn't
recommend joe biden calling like having
a gang but for us
it was a way to rally our supporters and
help them feel part of the campaign um
and then um
from there on we had to go find that
tribe because actually when we first
announced yang gang it didn't like take
off it was like a slow
burn if you will if you i don't know if
you remember correctly but so
approximately what month was this
it was
it was probably early january i think we
did a yang gang we started using it in
early january 2019 and i think we had a
we wanted to up our just
we just thought it was better to have
more donors
uh from our email list so we we actually
started taking venmo
i remember trying to take money through
venmo but i i kind of was like oh we
should do it totally because that's like
the easiest thing for a young person so
he then got people giving us one dollar
via venmo
um
which is
uh we violated a whole bunch of
obviously rules doing that we had to go
back and
paper it up it's fine yeah that's got
the other fine it was great because we
had like a you know five four thousand
five thousand person email list and it
got us like fifty percent of that email
list eventually donated which is really
good if like for numbers-wise because it
was so simple just click and send a
venmo dollar
well this truly is uh the beginning of
the rise because it's january 2019
and
around then they announced the criteria
to get on the debate stage which was the
push to get 65 000 individual donors sam
harris helped a lot we knew like what we
wanted to be
and then we just needed to find them and
so the traditional playbook where you
get the pundits in this the
the endorsers and the mainstream media
and the high dollar donors and the
political consultant who weren't getting
any of those so we had to go the other
way when we went
podcasts and alternative media and
social media i do a lot of wired and
uh tech press when i say we built the
yang gang and the book i said we built
the yang gang with podcasts memes and
math uh
and so podcasts were like this long form
way to get your message out uh
with people who were
more ripe to hear it i think um
and you got really good at talking on
podcasts
you had a lot of practice 2018 and sam
harris you really refined it and by joe
rogan you were in your zone you pretty
much did all of them in middle of 2019
all your big ones um
and then memes were like a fun way to
let the yang gang in where they could
make my favorite meme i talked about in
the book and you guys can find this it's
like the arnold schwarzenegger
terminator meme where he's
uh
he's riding a motorcycle next to a uh
there's he's saving john connor who's
also riding a motorcycle and there's a
big semi truck coming and he's about to
crush john connor and terminator comes
up and pulls him out of the way and the
truck crushes john connor's motorcycle
and it's like andrew yang's john connor
and the truck is automation and
john connor or andre yang's the
terminator saving john connor john
commerce the american economy whatever
it is um but we posted workers yeah we
posted on the
official yang like social accounts and
he was like yank and meme was like one
of the first and i was like rock toaster
whatever his name was on twitter it was
like the handle was pretty funny um
but we started just leaning into memes
all the time and a really good way to
like make it fun uh secure the bag like
stuff like that started coming out and
we just like if the yang gang posted
something fun we fired up right we
leaned into it in the beginning you were
still like a business speaker you know
um
and i joke in the we're trying to get
you to fire up the crowd it's like not
your natural
uh you can do really well now but at the
beginning you never had to really yeah
no hitting emotional chords was not the
[ __ ] tenor
and so we were trying to get you like
fire people up and you were just like
to your credit like really trying trying
to figure this out and you're like give
all your your speech everybody's
captivated and then you're like now
who's with me or what like you were like
it was like kind of it was it was a it
wasn't landing
and frawley had the idea is like why
don't we just give people
math signs like what he's like yeah so
when he says numbers he can be like
and we're like
i don't know that might be [ __ ]
brilliant man
so
uh so it was in baltimore right here
baltimore was right after joe rogan we
hadn't really hit a hit yet because it
just came out right um but it was a
decent crowd
and
a couple hundred people and we had
[ __ ] up so many ways in this rally
like so first of all we had the signs
and we forgot to print them double-sided
because so the the photos of the back of
the crowd it's just a white piece of
paper up there like oh [ __ ] hold them
backwards it was awful um
but then we did the other thing we
[ __ ] up we didn't tell you that we
were doing this math thing so you're
like oh i've looked at the numbers and
then all the crowd just starts going
math and you're like
oh
and then they went nuts again like yeah
and you're like [ __ ] yeah let's do some
[ __ ] math and like play some nuts oh
my god we nailed this um
but it was also
you know it was a i loved it because it
just hit this shitty stereotype we dealt
with all time right on the [ __ ] nose
you know where people are like oh
you're an asian guy you must you know
like numbers or
you're doing the math then you're like
[ __ ] yeah i'm just gonna lean into it
like you know you can't you're gonna use
it like tease me or just diminish me
like [ __ ] you i'll wear a math hat i'll
wear a math pin like screw you and it
was awesome because like whoa all right
like well you beat me to the punch there
uh
let's talk about something else right it
was uh i love stuff that defuses a bomb
like that and it was uh a big believer
in like leaning into you authentically
and the fact was you did use a lot of
numbers you did like i do use a lot of
numbers you know some woman
like a
media outlet was like don't use math
i've worked in brand marketing forever
i'll never catch on like man well screw
you
we got that so we got bad advice all the
time it it caught on
uh so on the next podcast which is going
to be on thursday we're going to talk
about the rise
2019 the debates and all of that but in
the meantime get your own copy of long
shot how political nobody is that zack
took andrew yang that's me national and
the new playbook that let us build a
movement by first time author i'm sure
not the last zach grauman zach
congratulations the book is tremendous i
had a blast reading it
it was a trip down memory lane for me
but anyone who had any
uh
investment emotionally in our campaign
is gonna love it and it truly is the
book that a lot of people
uh hoped i would write and as usual you
did it and i didn't uh so congrats man i
i'm so pumped for this to be in people's
hands thanks man uh yeah to be continued
huh
[Music]
[Music]
you